ça va il vous a pas fait main sais pas
comment vous remercier
j'ai comme celle sur moi c'est tout ce
que j'ai si je vous en donne dit ça va
bon moi si vous insistez je vais prendre
les 20 alors merci au président du
vêtement robin il faut pas comment c'est
quoi toutes ces questions là vous êtes
de la police ou quoi robin des bois et
caresse parce qu'il ya plusieurs super
enchanté petit jean robin le gang de
sherwood c'est nous
c'est le shérif qui tient les rênes on
vole aux riches pour donner aux pauvres
on va lui ait volé les impôts qui nous a
volé
quand
et en plus ils ont prévu un petit combat
léger cerveau c'est quoi qu'il arrive tu
peux voler les informer des malades
veulent que les pauvres femmes et vieux
les avions n'est pas restée trop
dangereux on fait pas seulement à vos
yeux et gens ne doivent pas donner
beaucoup
c'est pas possible raconte encore
content parce que j'ai pas content et
c'est ça parce que je suis arabe c'est
parce que je suis au monde c'est parce
que je suis juif tout est juste
maintenant ça fait bien longtemps que
kim pêcher un intrus sa marque pour
quoique pas sortir avec ma mère regarde
elle est dégueulasse on dit d'un homme
c'est quoi ça je les envoyais
redistribue matin on valorise pour
donner aux pauvres
et comment ils vous remboursent du cou
par une cagoule jours parce que je
pourrai le faire
pourquoi c'est moi qui dois frapper
parce que je suis petit c'est ça parce
que je suis homo non c'est pas parce que
tu es en moi parce que je suis arabe
je me rends si vous n'y verrez mes amis
je me rends sujets divers pas ils
étaient bill
des claquettes étendue dira je leur dis
ce n'est pas le temps de réagir ils
m'ont tout court juste après par
derrière tu m'écoutes pas non mais parce
que tu as la tête tournée